[Musique]
ça a été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je l'envoie.
le procès-verbal et donc adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
monsieur le Premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
collègues
c'est avec émotion que nous avons appris
hier matin
le président Marseille et moi-même
le décès de notre collègue Catherine
Fournier
sénatrice du Pas-de-Calais
maire de frethun pendant 22 ans
elle a mis tout son énergie et sa
générosité au service de sa commune
conseiller régional des Hauts de France
c'est le chef d'entreprise une défenseur
passionné du Calaisis
Catherine Fournier c'est pleinement
appliquer dans la vie démocratique de
son département et de sa région au côté
de Xavier Bertrand
c'est shop de conviction de 20 sénatrice
pour renouvellement de 2017
membres du groupe de l'Union centriste
et les jusqu'au bout rester fidèle à son
l'idéal humaniste et à son engagement au
service des autres
pendant 4 années à nos côtés en ce
fauteuil juste en face de moi
oui pendant ces 4 années car ils font 10
a éclairé la commission des Affaires
sociales la commission des Affaires
européennes puis la commission des
Affaires économiques par sa connaissance
des dossiers
le président de la commission spéciale
sur le projet de loi relatif à la
croissance et la transformation des
entreprises avec la plus grande rigueur
j'ai avec les membres de la conférence
des présidents j'en suis certain le
souvenir ses interventions à la fois
éclairé par l'expérience et pragmatique
et j'ai le souvenir
des vacances pour que certains articles
de ce texte à examiner dans le cadre de
la toute nouvelle législation en
commission sur le Ministre chargé des
relations avec le Parlement je crois que
vous en souvenez aussi
l'auteur d'un rapport d'information aux
côtés de Michel Forissier de Frédéric
puisse
sur le droit social applicable aux
travailleurs des plateformes qui marqua
le Sénat par sa qualité
chanson c' politique conjuguer à son
sérieux et à sa gentillesse ont marqué
tout ce qu'ils ont eu la chance de
travailler à ses côtés
elle s'est battu avec un courage
incroyable contre La Valette
quel sens est l'espérance
je suis accompagné avec tendresse et
dévouement par son époux sa famille et
ses collègues je me souviens d'un
échange récent que j'ai eu avec elle au
téléphone elle me parlait des travaux de
notre assemblée alors qu'elle partait
une fois encore suivre le protocole de
traitement
au nom du Sénat je suis certain du Sénat
tout entier et bien au-delà tu sais là
je souhaite exprimer notre sympathie et
notre profond de compassion à son époux
et ses enfants à ses proches ainsi qu'on
président et aux membres du groupe de
l'Union sens triste et à tous ses
collègues qui l'ont connu en commission
je vous propose d'observer un instant de
recueillement
je vous remercie
[Musique]